I don't think they do a disservice I
wouldn't put it that they're doing a
disservice i would say that they're
missing an incredible opportunity to be
role models and to be leaders and to
help lead the next generation toward
equality and fairness for all people
without regard to sexual orientation we
know that there are closeted celebrities
we know there are closeted politician
still we know there are closeted CEOs or
positive people sitting behind cameras
that do this kind of work it's just
always the way it is what we talk about
is how when someone chooses to live
openly it transforms not just themselves
but it has an impact on people that are
around them and all the people that they
know so we we encourage people to tell
their story to their neighbors to their
friends in their neighborhoods in their
workplace where they're able to be
comfortable and do it in a way that
enables them to live authentically you
know we don't even like to use the term
coming out anymore coming out is sort of
a term that goes back to the 60s and 70s
when people literally had to still be
hidden society doesn't require us to be
as hidden as it used to so we encourage
people to live openly and live
authentically and to allow themselves to
be full members of society and and do
that by allowing your sexual orientation
to be a part of who you are
reality TV and shows on cable really
have been among the leaders in having
those fair and accurate portrayal of the
LGBT community you think back to it was
only nineteen ninety-four so fourteen
years ago pedro zamora on the real world
you may be too young to some of your
viewers may be too young to do that
remember that but you know Pedro really
was the first openly gay latino
hiv-positive guy on the real world
talking about his life and showing to
not just people in in the house there
but to everyone who watched the real
world that he was very authentic and
very real and very genuine and over time
shows like that over time have really
been transformative and helping helping
people understand that their neighbors
their co-workers their friends down the
street are all part of the broader
society and many of them are in the LGBT
community the glaad media awards really
is what the gay lesbian alliance against
defamation is most known for it's our
most visible brand and it's the way that
glad honors and recognizes those
individuals and organizations and
outlets in the media or television shows
films that get it right who have used a
fair accurate and inclusive
representation of the gay community in
telling their stories whether it's a TV
show or a film or a journalist a
newspaper article whatever it may be
magazines and so recently here in New
York we honored Brian Graydon who's the
president of MTV entertainment for the
work that Brian has done over his entire
career not just in reality television
which is what people first probably
think of but just by being an out
executive himself and by being a role
model within within his world within the
entertainment industry I was done in
just a tremendous driving room and
Brian's work in television really helped
raise MTV specifically really helped
raise a whole generation of people who
don't see sexual orientation as a big
issue it's just the way it is and that
really is a tremendous legacy for Brian
and his work we also honored Judy
Shepard as a straight ally who for
almost ten years now has been just so on
our side speaking out against hate and
bigotry and speaking for fairness and
equality
probably more than any other straight
advocate I can think of you know and
just think of you know in the wake of
the tragedy that she had to deal with
almost 10 years ago she stood up and
wanted to make a difference and has now
spoken to over a million people in the
last 10 years over a million people have
SAT and listened to Judy tell her story
about trying to end hate and
discrimination a very very powerful
story and an amazing woman that we were
honoured in Los Angeles we're taking a
tilt towards the entertainment community
we're honoring Janet Jackson someone who
has embraced her gay fans from day one
has spoken out in favor of the gay
community particularly involved with
helping raise funds for AIDS HIV
community we within the gay community
and has been are just a real real great
ally for the community and ellen
degeneres is going to come and present
that award to janet on april 26th we're
also honoring an out performer who's
really tremendous and rufus wainwright
and just an amazing performer an amazing
talent who's been an out entertainer and
performer for many many many years and
is deserving of our recognition as well
and then we're also honoring the Herb
Ritts foundation when he was alive and
even since his passing the work of herb
ritts has inspired a lot of people with
a tremendous way he captured people and
in photographs and then shared them and
Cindy Crawford is coming to accept that
award on behalf of the Herb Ritts
foundation in Tom Ford one of our
honorees from last year at our show here
in New York City is going to be
presenting that award to Cindy so it's
really going to be a great night